[Music]
new push back against canceled culture
and it comes from some prominent liberal
figures with JK rowling Gloria Steinem
Noam Chomsky and others signing an open
letter published by Harper's calling for
openness to opposing views joining me
now is Dave Rubin host of the Rubin
report it's pretty fascinating this
whole episode because as soon as the
letter comes out you had people
apologize I just want to read one of
these tweets to you from Jennifer Finney
Boylan who had signed the letter and she
said I did not know who else had signed
it I thought I was endorsing a
well-meaning
if vague message against Internet
shaming I did note ROM skee Steinem
Annette wood were in and I thought good
company but the consequences are mine to
bear and I am so sorry
so she canceled herself Dave oh the web
we weave when we decide to cancel
everybody I mean look it's nice we're
all glad to see it right it's nice to
see liberals finally coming around and
realizing Oh cancel culture isn't about
just taking out conservatives it might
take them out too but for the record
there's a couple people who sign this
thing who've tried to cancel me so it's
nice but ultimately it's just a bunch of
words and I don't see the radicals
looking at this thing and going okay
let's wrap up cancel culture if anything
they've proven here that they're gonna
keep attacking and people that have
signed it are gonna back out do you
think that anyone that signed this
letter would defend conservatives that
are attacked I'm sure there's a couple
people on there who would and I'm sure
there's a couple of people on there who
have but for the most part no I mean
look every one of the people that's on
that list when they when the mob comes
for them it's gonna be the lefty mob
it's not gonna be the Trump supporters
it's not gonna be the scary
conservatives or anyone on the right
it's gonna be the lefties that come for
their schools that come for their jobs
that come for their homes and their
families so again this is
them just kind of protecting their last
bastion of freedom but they should have
been protecting a lot of other people
before this you saw it coming you wrote
the book
don't burn this book I wish I was wrong
Dana honestly I really do yeah well
you're not wrong and you're always
welcome here on the show we appreciate
it dave rubin and hope that clyde and
your puppy is sitting by your feet there
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell